they had come in their thousands
once again calling for prime minister
prayut chanocha to resign
the protesters vowed to remain until
their demands were met
the next morning the government hit back
it arrested opposition leaders
and removed demonstrators camped out in
front of the prime minister's office
it also banned gatherings of more than
five people
and the publication of news it deems a
security threat
the anti-government rallies started in
july apart from fresh elections and a
new constitution
the opposition also wants to limit the
powers of the king
which has not gone down well with thai
royalists
i think the royalist supporters are out
here because they love the country
we love the country as well i'm not
worried about violence because both
sides are doing what they think is best
for the country
but scuffles did break out between
opponents and supporters of the monarchy
thailand's royal family is backed by the
military and traditionally revered by
the population
but king maha what shira longhorn is
less popular than his father
who died in 2016. the king's motorcade
met with chance in a three-fingered
salute
unthinkable in earlier times the gesture
has become a pro-democracy symbol
borrowed from the hunger games film
series about a totalitarian regime
harsh laws have stifled public criticism
of the monarchy
but the king has stirred dissent with
his extravagant lifestyle
and long holidays abroad during the
pandemic
opposition leader anon nampa called out
the king on stage during the protests
our king does not reside in thailand i'd
like to ask directly
what's so bad about living in thailand
he was later arrested with the anger
boiling over
the government is keen to put a lid on
the protests any way it can
well for more now i'm joined by
professor titi nan
pong sudhirak at chula longhorn
university in bangkok
professor protests are nothing new in
thailand but
these seem different what's driving
people to take to the streets
this time so persistently
well if you follow thai politics you
know you've seen um street
demonstrations and
protests and polarizations over the last
15 years
punctuated by two military crews in 2006
2014
two new constitutions in 2007-2017
this time the protests are being led by
a different generation
and they're making different demands and
this is a younger generation younger
voices basically people
under their 40s i mean people in their
20s and 30s
they have seen over the last 15 years
that you know they they have no future
because thailand is at a standstill
time has been set by nepotism corruption
economic risk management
no growth strategy going forward so for
them these younger
people younger demographics they want to
reclaim
their future for jobs for livelihoods
and so on
they're also making a different kind of
demands for thailand it's a
profoundly new set of demands to to call
for
you know the prime minister's
resignation we've seen that kind of
demand before but
a new constitution in order to reset to
recalibrate we make thai democracy into
a genuine democratic system
and the most profound of all that we've
not heard of before is unprecedented is
the reform of the monarchy
and these three demands a tall order for
thailand
yet you know these young people are not
gonna go away because they they want
their future back they want time to move
ahead
so we're seeing a lot of tension now
because they're not being
accommodated there's no concession no
compromise only a crackdown
you mentioned the monarchy kings are
traditionally revered
in thai society why have the protesters
turned against the monarchy and
how significant is this
well you know if you if you look at
thailand from outside
you have to understand that uh thailand
as we know it today and this is a
significant country 17 million people
population
20th most populous country in the world
as a
sizable gdp is a you know main country
in
the hub of mainland southeast asia so
it's an important country
and this country has been known all of
the
all what we know about thailand comes
from the one rain under the
the throne and the reign of king rama
the ninth king
the laking and now there's a new monarch
so it's a new era
the reason people are so uh you know
respectful and they find the king the
laking so popular is because
we went through communist threat under
the communist threat so we had this uh
all around thailand you can see you know
indochina
burma and so on a lot the neighborhood
had a hard time but thailand
persevered and got through the communist
era at the same time thailand had
economic development and the laking
devoted himself
to the betterment of the country for
china's development so people
respected that they appreciated that but
now with the new era i think a lot of
people also think that thailand needs to
change to reform
in order to move to the 21st century in
order to arrive in the 21st century
because they all institutions of the
monarchy the military the bureaucracy
judiciary don't work the same way as
they did before
okay let's get back to the crackdown
that the government has
launched now against the protesters do
you think that that crack town is likely
to stop
these protests
in the short term you know this is a
very
anxious 10th day in bangkok because the
crackdown comes with a
a severe imposition of emergency
decree which means it has empowered
the authorities to arrest detain people
there's a kind of a suppression taking
place now
certainly in the short term this means
that the protest movement
will have a we'll face a setback because
the leaders will be arrested
and there'll be more arrests i'm sure
some imprisonment
but in a longer term you know it's not
about the protesters and the protests
it's about the grievances that are
backing them that are behind them
so unless these businesses are addressed
somehow
we will see them back for long professor
thank you very
much we really appreciate your insights
on this complex story that was professor
titinan pong sudirak
thank you very much thank you
you